peut-être kenyans et nous semble
positive avec cependant des
recommandations positif au sens où la
valeur universelle exceptionnelle du
bien a été reconnu à nouveau par contre
où des raisons stratégiques
suite au revers avec les volcans
d'auvergne le comité français au
patrimoine mondial nous recommande un
bien transfrontalier avec la dominique
sur ce nous avons fait référence à
l'analyse comparative entre le biais de
la martinique est démontré que notre
pied avait une valeur exceptionnelle
university universel supérieur à celui
de la dominique son exercice difficile
pour autant on espère l'avoir réussi
parce que la difficulté maintenant c'est
que chaque état membre de l'unesco ne
peut présenter qu'un seul dossier par
année donc nous sommes en concurrence
avec d'autres projets notamment le
projet de nîmes sur le dos et culture
mais nous espérons que malgré tout avec
les recommandations nous allons
continuer à compléter notre dossier de
manière à ce qu'il soit excellent et
qu'ils soient déposés le haut avant le
1er février 2019
j'y vois un atout pour deux raisons
d'abord parce qu'une candidature
transnationale ou multinationale a
davantage de chances de réussir réunir
des bois tout simplement puis
deuxièmement il ya peu de biens qui sont
classées au titre des caraïbes
et donc voilà c'est la france c'est la
martinique au sein des caraïbes avec
tous les liens qu'on connaît culturelle
des liens de voisinage des liens aussi
de géographie c'est un atout
supplémentaire
le comité français il est là pour
préparer une candidature international
il est là pour sélectionner et il est là
pour préparer pour donner les meilleures
chances possibles à cette candidature
qui j'espère sera celle du par coeur
de naturel de martinique et de la
montagne pelée et pour réunir le plus de
chances possibles
il est mieux d'avoir une candidature qui
soit transnationales plutôt qu'une
candidature uniquement française donc
c'est un conseil que nous a demandé nous
a donné le comité français de gestion du
mien et c'est un conseil que nous avons
choisi de suivre